Our last episode brought us to the start of
the 20th century, where early, special purpose
computing devices, like tabulating machines,
were a huge boon to governments and business
- aiding, and sometimes replacing, rote manual
tasks. But the scale of human systems continued
to increase at an unprecedented rate.
The first half of the 20th century saw the
world’s population almost double. World
War 1 mobilized 70 million people, and World
War 2 involved more than 100 million.
Global trade and transit networks became interconnected
like never before, and the sophistication
of our engineering and scientific endeavors
reached new heights – we even started to
seriously consider visiting other planets.
And it was this explosion of complexity, bureaucracy,
and ultimately data, that drove an increasing
need for automation and computation. Soon those cabinet-sized electro-mechanical
computers grew into room-sized behemoths that
were expensive to maintain and prone to errors.
And it was these machines that would set the
stage for future innovation.
INTRO
One of the largest electro-mechanical computers
built was the Harvard Mark I, completed in
1944 by IBM for the Allies during World War 2.
It contained 765,000 components, three
million connections, and five hundred miles of wire.
To keep its internal mechanics synchronized,
it used a 50-foot shaft running right through
the machine driven by a five horsepower motor.
One of the earliest uses for this technology
was running simulations for the Manhattan Project.
The brains of these huge electro-mechanical
beasts were relays: electrically-controlled
mechanical switches. In a relay, there is
a control wire that determines whether a circuit
is opened or closed. The control wire connects
to a coil of wire inside the relay. When current
flows through the coil, an electromagnetic
field is created, which in turn, attracts
a metal arm inside the relay, snapping it
shut and completing the circuit. You can think
of a relay like a water faucet. The control
wire is like the faucet handle. Open the faucet,
and water flows through the pipe. Close the
faucet, and the flow of water stops.
Relays are doing the same thing, just with
electrons instead of water. The controlled
circuit can then connect to other circuits,
or to something like a motor, which might
increment a count on a gear, like in Hollerith's
tabulating machine we talked about last episode.
Unfortunately, the mechanical arm inside of
a relay *has mass*, and therefore can’t
move instantly between opened and closed states.
A good relay in the 1940’s might be able
to flick back and forth fifty times in a second.
That might seem pretty fast, but it’s not
fast enough to be useful at solving large,
complex problems.
The Harvard Mark I could do 3 additions or
subtractions per second; multiplications took
6 seconds, and divisions took 15.
And more complex operations, like a trigonometric function, could take over a minute.
In addition to slow switching speed, another
limitation was wear and tear. Anything mechanical
that moves will wear over time. Some things
break entirely, and other things start getting
sticky, slow, and just plain unreliable.
And as the number of relays increases, the
probability of a failure increases too. The
Harvard Mark I had roughly 3500 relays. Even
if you assume a relay has an operational life
of 10 years, this would mean you’d have
to replace, on average, one faulty relay every
day! That’s a big problem when you are in
the middle of running some important, multi-day
calculation.
And that’s not all engineers had to contend
with. These huge, dark, and warm machines
also attracted insects. In September 1947,
operators on the Harvard Mark II pulled a
dead moth from a malfunctioning relay. Grace Hopper who we’ll talk more about in a later episode noted,
“From then on, when anything went wrong with a computer,
we said it had bugs in it.”
And that’s where
we get the term computer bug.
It was clear that a faster, more reliable
alternative to electro-mechanical relays was
needed if computing was going to advance further,
and fortunately that alternative already existed!
In 1904, English physicist John Ambrose Fleming
developed a new electrical component called
a thermionic valve, which housed two electrodes
inside an airtight glass bulb - this was the
first vacuum tube. One of the electrodes could
be heated, which would cause it to emit electrons
– a process called thermionic emission.
The other electrode could then attract these
electrons to create the flow of our electric
faucet, but only if it was positively charged
- if it had a negative or neutral charge,
the electrons would no longer be attracted
across the vacuum so no current would flow.
An electronic component that permits the one-way
flow of current is called a diode, but what
was really needed was a switch to help turn
this flow on and off. Luckily, shortly after,
in 1906, American inventor Lee de Forest added
a third “control” electrode that sits
between the two electrodes in Fleming’s design.
By applying a positive charge to the
control electrode, it would permit the flow
of electrons as before. But if the control
electrode was given a negative charge, it
would prevent the flow of electrons.
So by manipulating the control wire, one could
open or close the circuit. It’s pretty much
the same thing as a relay - but importantly,
vacuum tubes have no moving parts. This meant
there was less wear, and more importantly,
they could switch thousands of times per second.
These triode vacuum tubes would become the
basis of radio, long distance telephone, and
many other electronic devices for nearly a
half century. I should note here that vacuum
tubes weren’t perfect - they’re kind of
fragile, and can burn out like light bulbs,
they were a big improvement over mechanical relays.
Also, initially vacuum tubes were expensive
– a radio set often used just one, but a
computer might require hundreds or thousands of electrical switches.
But by the 1940s,
their cost and reliability had improved to
the point where they became feasible for use
in computers…. at least by people with deep
pockets, like governments.
This marked the shift from electro-mechanical
computing to electronic computing. Let’s
go to the Thought Bubble.
The first large-scale use of vacuum tubes
for computing was the Colossus Mk 1 designed
by engineer Tommy Flowers and completed in
December of 1943. The Colossus was installed
at Bletchley Park, in the UK, and helped to
decrypt Nazi communications.
This may sound familiar because two years
prior Alan Turing, often called the father
of computer science, had created an electromechanical
device, also at Bletchley Park, called the
Bombe. It was an electromechanical machine
designed to break Nazi Enigma codes, but the
Bombe wasn’t technically a computer, and
we’ll get to Alan Turing’s contributions
later.
Anyway, the first version of Colossus contained
1,600 vacuum tubes, and in total, ten Colossi
were built to help with code-breaking.
Colossus is regarded as the first programmable, electronic computer.
Programming was done by plugging hundreds
of wires into plugboards, sort of like old
school telephone switchboards, in order to
set up the computer to perform the right operations.
So while “programmable”, it still had
to be configured to perform a specific computation.
Enter the The Electronic Numerical Integrator
and Calculator – or ENIAC – completed
a few years later in 1946 at the University
of Pennsylvania.
Designed by John Mauchly and J. Presper Eckert, this was the world's first truly general purpose,
programmable, electronic computer.
ENIAC could perform 5000 ten-digit additions
or subtractions per second, many, many times
faster than any machine that came before it.
It was operational for ten years, and is estimated
to have done more arithmetic than the entire
human race up to that point.
But with that many vacuum tubes failures were
common, and ENIAC was generally only operational
for about half a day at a time before breaking
down.
Thanks Thought Bubble. By the 1950’s, even
vacuum-tube-based computing was reaching its limits.
The US Air Force’s AN/FSQ-7 computer,
which was completed in 1955, was part of the
“SAGE” air defense computer system we’ll
talk more about in a later episode.
To reduce cost and size, as well as improve
reliability and speed, a radical new electronic
switch would be needed. In 1947, Bell Laboratory
scientists John Bardeen, Walter Brattain,
and William Shockley invented the transistor,
and with it, a whole new era of computing was born!
The physics behind transistors is
pretty complex, relying on quantum mechanics,
so we’re going to stick to the basics.
A transistor is just like a relay or vacuum
tube - it’s a switch that can be opened
or closed by applying electrical power via
a control wire. Typically, transistors have
two electrodes separated by a material that
sometimes can conduct electricity, and other
times resist it – a semiconductor.
In this case, the control wire attaches to
a “gate” electrode. By changing the electrical
charge of the gate, the conductivity of the
semiconducting material can be manipulated,
allowing current to flow or be stopped – like
the water faucet analogy we discussed earlier.
Even the very first transistor at Bell Labs
showed tremendous promise – it could switch
between on and off states 10,000 times per second.
Further, unlike vacuum tubes made
of glass and with carefully suspended, fragile
components, transistors were solid material known as a solid state component.
Almost immediately, transistors could be made smaller than the smallest possible relays or vacuum tubes.
This led to dramatically smaller and cheaper computers, like the IBM 608, released in 1957
– the first fully transistor-powered, commercially-available computer.
It contained 3000 transistors and
could perform 4,500 additions, or roughly
80 multiplications or divisions, every second.
IBM soon transitioned all of its computing
products to transistors, bringing transistor-based
computers into offices, and eventually, homes.
Today, computers use transistors that are
smaller than 50 nanometers in size – for
reference, a sheet of paper is roughly 100,000
nanometers thick. And they’re not only incredibly
small, they’re super fast – they can switch
states millions of times per second, and can run for decades.
A lot of this transistor and semiconductor development happened in the Santa Clara  Valley,
between San Francisco and San Jose, California.
As the most common material used
to create semiconductors is silicon, this
region soon became known as Silicon Valley.
Even William Shockley moved there, founding
Shockley Semiconductor, whose employees later
founded
Fairchild Semiconductors, whose employees
later founded
Intel - the world’s largest computer chip
maker today.
Ok, so we’ve gone from relays to vacuum
tubes to transistors. We can turn electricity
on and off really, really, really fast. But
how do we get from transistors to actually
computing something, especially if we don’t
have motors and gears?
That’s what we’re going to cover over
the next few episodes.
Thanks for watching. See you next week.